you know we talked about this little
turning point that you know i went to
turning point for a bunch of years but
cpac the first time i went i was a
college student i'm a i'm a proud nerd i
describe myself as such in college but i
went to cpac and i loved it because i
had this passion for politics this
burning desire in my heart and cpac gave
me a place to go be like other young
students like myself and hear from the
greatest thought leaders in our party um
you know to have gone as a student and
to come back and see it full circle
young people older people just so
passionate standing up for their country
gives you optimism it gives you hope for
sure
these days what do i love about it the
most i know i get to hang out with
kaylee okay because we get to do this
show on fox fox nation which is a lot of
fun all access live think about it we do
get to come here and they bring all the
coolest people right to us and then we
get to talk to them on camera and it the
feeling though is it's what is neat is
that it does have a family very much a
family movement feel to it a purposeful
feel to it but it's also a back to
basics feel it's like we're not we're
not debating esoteric theories about
random federal programs it's about the
flag and about freedom and about faith
and families and that's why we have such
an opportunity as a movement right now
we've we've been pulled so far in the
culture
we're we're planting a flag right where
it should be which is right in the
middle of the american consciousness not
anywhere far right at all america first
is simple and its building blocks and
cpac does a great job of build bringing
those people
together and sometimes like like turning
point it's a bit of a therapy session
everybody but these days it's more than
that it's it is a it's a re-arming
rebuilding for an opportunity to take
the country back like you said this is
uh that's what it's all about patriotism
is alive and well here like there's no
doubt